welcome back to be rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and a long-lost deleted scene from
Thor Ragnarok has leaked online and even
though the movie came out a few years
back long before they know skåne endure
lives
freezy it's pretty fascinating to go
back and pull this thing apart for the
odd ways title with TT's early cut of
the film almost went and for clues
pointing to wide ct's plans for the
upcoming throw in love and thunder
connections to Avengers endgame and
future mythology in the MCU so let us
work it down okay this was the alternate
Odin death scene that wat TT shot early
in production which we saw some leaked
set photos more with anthony hopkins
dressed as a homeless person after
outing loki is the imposter Odin on
Asgard Thor takes him to New York where
in the final cut they discover that the
retirement home Loki left Odin in has
been demolished leaving the two to dr.
Strange's sanctum sanctorum and search
for Odin's new location which they find
to be the cliffs of norway and was in
this reshot version of the scene where
odin peacefully fades away leading to
Hellas arrival and destruction of
Mjolnir but a trailer breaker Downer's
remember a shot from the Ragnarok promo
showing hella cracking that roof in an
urban alleyway not a grassy cliffside so
we know this sequence was changed and
only now do we get to see the full
original version so let's take a look
have you done the movie I had to strip
him of his memories this guy's his
existence I found it first
I found it it's alright we're here to
take you home oh that's right there's no
home there's no hope
Aska there's not a place brother's reef
fool I know my son like so right away we
can see why what tt reshot this despite
Hopkins impressive commitment to the bit
it might have been a step too far in
Thai cos wacky irreverence that works so
well throughout the rest of Ragnarok but
yeah a bit much to see the esteemed
ruler of Asgard collapse into a babbling
sick old man yeah it's a kind of sad but
hey we can still laugh like [ __ ]
because check it out Odin's wearing a
red sweater gloves
he's got unkempt hair guys this is the
exact same look the war takes on when he
later lets himself go and endgame it's
as if they considered this states too
deep of a rock bottom for the great Odin
but for Thor's rock bottom hell yeah
let's turn that rock bottom into a flat
e1
I also like how aggressive Odin is about
the booze that he found just
how slob thorn in game was all about
that new has Gardel and the has Guardian
liquor he was looking for during the
time heist and among Odin's mutterings
is the phrase Asgard is not a place one
cool element of crazy old Odin in this
deleted scene is that his words actually
end up having meaning throughout the
story that would follow Thor and Loki
here this as just cryptic nonsense and
act 1 but by the end of the film Asgard
is not a place would bear the deeper
thematic message as the to bleed the
Asgardian refugees away from the ruins
of their home Asgard is not a place it's
a people people people no moving your
lawless nature the stones within you you
inherited from me you are my son both
bye son I'm sorry I failed Tom
Hiddleston plays this moment was such
great heartbreak over Odin recognizing
him as his son he actually had a similar
reaction in the reshot version of the
scene
I sons and in this case it's even sadder
because Loki just told Thor that he
wiped Odin's memories
it's Loki's fault that Odin is so senile
here yet still I was able to break
through this senility to connect with
his sons and notice the posters on
alleyway walls one says journey into
mystery a nod to the title of the Atlas
comics series in which Thor debuted in
1962 and another shot to the alleyway
you could see posters reading thunder
and love suggesting that Taika Waititi
had the idea for the title love and
thunder in his head for several years
and in the context of the scene the
words reflect the emotional subtext Odin
is passing his love and his thunder on
to his boys he mentions the storms with
in new words that will later apply
greatly to Thor whose abilities of the
god of thunder are always within him
able to be harnessed with the help Neil
near onward the fall of asgaard I cannot
hold it back any longer who who you
talking about goddess and she comes with
chaos
Odin's beer is just so Shakespearean
like a crazy old soothsayer and while it
doesn't totally befit his character you
can see what my teacher was going for
here using Odin as a metaphor for how
Asgard as a whole has fallen into
despair it's time coming to an end now
I'm super fascinated by Norse mythology
and the whole concept of Ragnarok and
how this storm movie embraced that let
things in philosophy instead of Yuna
fighting it to force things into cheesy
happy endings and as I've been exploring
the subject one title that I have been
loving his Neil Gaiman's Norse mythology
you know Gaiman himself it's no stranger
to comics lore in their connection to
ancient myths right now I'm listening to
this on audible and this video is
brought to you by audible and their
unmatched selection of audiobooks and
other audio products give yourself the
gift of audible membership includes one
free audio book a month and two audible
originals unlike a streaming or rental
service with audible you own your books
and you get to keep them even if you
cancel in addition to gaymans Norse
mythology audible also has tons of dune
star wars game of Thrones titles it's
pretty much a sci-fi and fantasy audio
paradise members stay motivated and
inspired with unlimited access to
exclusive
rusev guided Fitness and meditation
programs perfect for helping you stick
with those New Year's resolutions
they have podcasts theatrical
performances a list comedy and exclusive
audible originals that you won't find
anywhere else
start listening with a 30 day audible
trial choose one audiobook and two
audible originals absolutely free just
visit audible.com slash new rock stars
or text new rock stars to 500 500 again
that's audible.com slash new rock stars
or text new rock stars - 500 500 for one
audiobook and two audible originals
absolutely free let's move on to the
rest of this deleted scene it's begun
already
there is no escape to seek out the fire
seek out the fire okay the portal VFX
are unrendered here because you know
they never released a scene no sense of
spend all the hours finishing it but
Odin tells Thor seek out the fire
blasting him with a premonition of fire
wiping out Asgard see again Odin's
nonsense is actually disguised wisdom
Odin its tasking Thor with finding the
eternal flame the one that they use to
awaken search her and as Thor returns
from the vision you can hear the
rumblings of a thunderclap kabab and
odin completes his Rite of succession in
the next clip
where's father deserve the piece cast
aside selfish ambition actually for the
good of the relevant where his father's
done settled I surrendered my power to
you okay Odin is passing on his
rulership of Asgard to Thor and passing
his powers on to him too but in doing so
he also leaves Loki with some fatherly
wisdom he says the word kneel what
Nate's almost as if he knows how pokey
used that word a few years earlier
[Music]
Odin is telling Loki you don't force
your subjects to kneel so they cower
before your might you ask them to kneel
as a symbol of respect for the
responsibility of a ruler to put aside
his selfish wishes and serve his people
next clip
seek out the fire okay hella arrives and
once again
Odin repeats seek out the fire knowing
at this point there is no chance to save
ass guard the only hope is to take down
hell with it
Loki and Thor power up Thor hits his
umbrella on the ground to turn it back
into Mjolnir as we saw in the final cut
it's a nod to the original Thor comics
in which Thor walked around in disguise
masky and his hammer as a walking stick
that he would tap on the ground to turn
back in for moving on you took
everything from me you gave up
everything to pursue your twisted team
your way is cold and brutal still is an
interesting moment between father and
daughter here later in the film hella
explains that she once fought alongside
her father there was a theory based on
Odin spare Infinity Gauntlet and his
vault that Odin and hella once pursued a
similar war path for the Infinity stones
that Thanos and Gamora would later
repeat but that Odin backed out at
Boromir so hella kills Odin and there's
another heartbreaking reaction by Loki
as he screams his face full of regret
that he abandoned his warrior father
into this undignified end
and while hella killing Odin would make
her a far more fearsome villain in this
film it does kind of muddy the equally
heavy emotional breaking point for Thor
which comes in the next clip
[Music]
yes here's the moment from the early
Ragnarok trailer that I mentioned see
and both this version in the final cut
it does remain a mystery what happened
to those shards of you that were left
behind because you know it's still a
valuable medieval Aryan or saying it
would be a very interesting loose end
for a future MCU film to pick back up
and as they teleport away in the by
process we get a great look at potatoey
CGI Thor and we move on to the final
seconds
[Music]
yes Odin's final words repeats the
deeper theme of Ragnarok that Asgard is
not a place it's a paid Paul and we get
this money shot of her sweeping back her
antlers god damn I hope tell us somehow
survived search her because I just love
this villain and I need her back in love
and thunder but which version of the
scene do you prefer comment down below
with your thoughts follow me at he a
boss follow new rock stars on social
media subscribe to the rock stars on
YouTube for breakdowns of everything you
love thank you for watching and remember
the blue dungeon it's not a place it's a
paint cool man it's the men showers
[Music]